[Musique]
nous avons été reçus dont parle jean
larcher et puis parce que sénateur alors
le 7 mai a vraiment montré la voie il a
montré la voie parce que toutes
tendances politiques confondues
nous avons non seulement été écoutés
mais très vite laissé la danse sont
donnés le moyen de nous accompagner sur
nos premières demandes et nous
accompagner en urgence le sénat a
considéré qu'il était nécessaire de
débloquer au moins 500 millions d'euros
sur ce milliard promis pour pouvoir
mettre en place un certain nombre
d'actions
[Musique]
l'avis de la création d'un fonds
spécifique de 200 millions qui je vous
le rappelle depuis a reçu un avis
contraire du gouvernement n'a pas de
date donc pas été retenu mais des moyens
spécifiques dans les parcours emploi
compétences la création de 80 sites et
de l'emploi supplémentaire et un zoom
très très important sur ce qui était de
l'éducatif c'est à dire 50 % de
programmes en plus sur la réussite
éducative 46 p éducatif supplémentaires
150% sur les fonds de la santé une
nouvelle impulsion pour le année npa et
rue